the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC let's start today with Ron DeSantis
now if you listen to our episodes or
watch the videos a day or two later than
we publish them we may already know the
answer to the question of whether Ron
DeSantis will or will not enter the 2024
Republican primary race speculation is
that he is going to announce if he will
announce as soon as this week but
extraordinarily fascinating is a new
report from The New York Times that
privately one of the ways that Ron
DeSantis has been trying to convince
major Republican donors to support him
instead of Donald Trump is by telling
the donors that Trump cannot win in 2024
now the interesting thing about this is
that in a strictly mathematical sense
based on polling DeSantis may actually
be making the most fact-based argument
that could be made about why someone
would choose DeSantis over Trump in the
Republican primary even if they are sort
of Maga people and we're going to look
at that polling but it's not wrong in a
strictly factual sense
for DeSantis to be making this argument
but is this the way to project strength
to those who are saying well we've got
the former president Trump but maybe I
want something different so I could
support someone else does IT project
strength for desantis's case to be
Trump can't win so give me money instead
we look at this report Biden and me
DeSantis privately tells donors Trump
can't win Governor Ron DeSantis of
Florida all but declared his
presidential candidacy Thursday
afternoon telling donors and supporters
on a call that only three credible
candidates were in the race and that
only he would be able to win both the
Republican primary and the general
election quote you have basically three
people at this point that are credible
in this whole thing
uh Biden Trump and me and I think of
those three two have a chance to get
elected President Biden and Me based on
all the data in the swing states which
is not great for the former president
and probably insurmountable because
people aren't going to change their view
of him
this is correct that it it's such a
unique situation in which we find
ourselves right now I believe that
DeSantis is right when we look at new
and recent polling of different kinds
um you see that uh let's see which of
these are the most relevant to what
we're talking about there's a Harris X
poll which is done in partnership with
Harvard if you look at that one Biden
DeSantis are even but Biden is losing to
Trump by seven that's an outlier in
which Trump does better against Biden
than DeSantis but you look at most
polling and Biden does better against
Trump than he does against Ron DeSantis
for example you have uh Biden actually
you know in reese is this turning around
I'm now looking at the last I looked at
this was Friday there's a bunch of new
polling which actually says that Biden
is doing better against DeSantis than
Trump so if the polling is turning
around maybe this is wrong but
historically uh Biden has done better
against Trump than DeSantis so let's
imagine that these last couple of polls
uh are outliers and don't represent the
broader picture DeSantis isn't wrong in
saying that if we were to get to a
general election match-up I do better
against Biden than Trump let's imagine
that that's true but this is a very weak
case to be making this is a sign of
desantis's insecurity and fear of trump
which is very clear which is to skip and
just say if we get to November I do
better whether or not that's true
because DeSantis doesn't really know how
to run against Trump so these are the
sorts of things he's relegated to
telling donors well it's not about I'm
going to do better with X group in the
South or whatever the case may be it's
Trump can't actually win and I could so
the idea is undermine Trump in front of
donors behind closed doors appeal to the
donors and say to them you need a more
viable alternative and I guess it's me I
don't know that this is an effective
strategy to win the Republican primary
that's the critical thing to understand
even if DeSantis is right he does better
against Biden than Trump or if he's
wrong
this is not a strategy that is going to
propel the santis to winning the
Republican nomination which he has to do
first because when you look at the
strategy of DeSantis on policy on the
one hand during Trump's presidency
DeSantis was a major Trump brown-noser
and sycophant DeSantis echoed some of
Trump's lies about the election
DeSantis echoed much of what Trump was
saying about covet even though now in
retrospect they're pretending that they
were really far apart on covid but you
look at immigration you look at voting
rights Banning books that criticize
Trump from public schools you look at
all these things this long period of
time they were in lockstep and in
retrospect now both are drawing
distinctions and trying to criticize the
other as saying they went the wrong way
I now represent the heart of the
Republican party that doesn't seem like
it's going to convince Mega people to
abandon Trump and support DeSantis and
that's what this is all about I'm
getting so wound up I just punched my
microphone I apologize to people
listening with headphones at the end of
the day this is a math or maths problem
uh DeSantis even if he gets all of the
current non-trump vote cannot get to 50
in the Republican primary and so when
you hear desantis's behind closed doors
telling donors Trump can't actually beat
Biden or whatever the case may be the
donors if they're at all connected to
reality should be looking at DeSantis
and saying listen Ron meatball whatever
they call them at this point even if we
believe you that you're the guy that can
beat by
this isn't going to help you beat Trump
who already has 55 56 57 percent of the
primary what exactly are you going to do
to turn Trump voters to your side and
DeSantis has no answer to that
whatsoever so DeSantis is doing the
thing that oftentimes primary candidates
who will lose are going to do look at
Nikki Haley Nikki Haley instead of going
after Trump other than to say I'm from a
different generation basically I'm
younger and I'm a woman Nikki Haley has
been mostly criticizing Joe Biden that's
a loser's strategy you're not explaining
how you win the primary when you just
say here are all the problems with Joe
Biden Trump spends all day criticizing
Joe Biden it's not going to convince
Republican voters so I'm as curious as
anybody else to see what happens if and
when to Santa centers this race that
maybe today that may be tomorrow or he
may say if if better judgment gets to
him I can't win this thing I'm going to
wait until 2028. I I struggled to
imagine DeSantis gets away from polling
20 and saying maybe I could double it
maybe I could triple it so we will know
much more very soon but in the meantime
DeSantis having major problems in the
State of Florida and I want to talk
about that next the NAACP is warning
black folks LGBT folks and other
minority groups
don't go to Florida
it's dangerous Ron DeSantis Florida is a
very dangerous place a very interesting
article from the Miami Herald says hate
inspired leadership NAACP joins other
groups in warning against travel to
Florida
the oldest Civil Rights group is
cautioning Travelers reconsider visits
to Florida as they join other advocates
in expressing distaste for the state's
openly hostile leadership the NAACP has
issued issued a travel advisory in
response to Ron DeSantis attempts to ban
books about race and lgbtq identity
reject a new AP class on
African-American studies ban diversity
equity and inclusion programs in Florida
colleges
quote Florida is openly hostile to
African Americans people of color lgbtq
plus individuals before traveling to
Florida please understand that the State
of Florida devalues and marginalizes the
contributions of and the challenges
faced by African Americans and other
communities of color and it also says if
you decide to travel to Florida be
advised Florida Public Schools won't
teach your children accurate
African-American history
um the State of Florida does not value
diversity equity and inclusion the State
of Florida doesn't welcome the
contributions of African Americans as
people of color
etc etc etc so a few different things to
this on the one hand sort of proving the
point
I saw wildly racist responses to this
online including people saying hey
Florida's only dangerous because of the
black people maybe this will keep black
people out of the state the right-wing
subreddit conservative was openly
celebrating hey you know what we should
welcome this this might make it so fewer
black people travel to Florida although
the post said less black people rather
than fewer but I'm giving it to you in a
grammatically correct way so a couple
different aspects to this first of all
the very reaction to this advisory by
the NAACP
roves much of what the NAACP is saying
period end of story
secondly the fact that in the U.S
there are Travel warnings to different
states based on this sort of thing
points to the retrograde and backwards
nature of what's going on in the United
States but lastly as a literal travel
advisory I don't know like for example
the first thing on the list is be aware
that if you travel to Florida
um your kids aren't going to be taught
XYZ most people traveling to Florida are
going on vacation they're not putting
their kids in school so I hesitate to
take this completely seriously as a
literal travel advisory but I think the
point here is to be more than a literal
travel advisory the idea here is bring
attention to what's going on in Florida
point to how these policies in Florida
disproportionately impact marginalized
communities of all kind black votes
folks LGBT folks women when it comes to
the abortion ban that has been passed
and their families of course so I see
this advisory
not as you know the advisory that the
U.S state department has about traveling
to the Sinaloa region of Mexico where
they say listen significant cartel
activity if you get into trouble there
you may be beyond help from the U.S
embassy this is not that this is not
that but it is a form of activism that
raises awareness and it encourages
dialogue and the need for rights and
protections and points to many of the
things that are going on going on and
going wrong in the State of Florida now
there are people who saw this advisory
and said this is very unfair this is
very unfair to Florida as a whole
because you have so many parts of
Florida where even if it is the case
that on paper teachers are not allowed
to do XYZ
um it is actually in the liberal parts
of Florida it is welcomed nobody is
blowing the whistle you look at places
like Miami and Miami Beach and other
liberal areas the LGBT community is
welcome there are absolutely no risk
danger whatsoever black folks are
welcomed and I have to tell you having
spent time in those areas I believe that
that's true but still it's really
important to understand the underlying
message here even if state decrees from
DeSantis are being ignored in the
liberal parts of Florida which to a
great degree they are
it is still the case that as a state
Florida is not fostering inclusivity
it's not promoting equality it's not
combating discrimination in fact it
seems to be building it so I think
let's not dismiss this outright because
it's not a literal travel advisory per
the interpretation of some let's use it
to remind ourselves of the right wing
hellscape that DeSantis is trying to
turn Florida into he hasn't yet
succeeded certainly not in all parts of
Florida but that's not a reason to
ignore this so a very interesting
declaration from the NAACP we're going
to take a quick break we have a packed
program today
um I do want to remind you that we are
just one week away from Monday Memorial
Day on Monday Memorial Day this year
that will be the 29th do I even know
what year it is yes May 29th we are
doing a one-day membership special doing
what we can to jump start support for
this program as we build into the 2024
election if you've been saying ah maybe
I'll get one of those memberships I
don't know David I I kind of like the
show but I don't like you enough to pay
full price
fair fair Monday morning we'll be
sending out an email to everyone on our
mailing list with an incredible coupon
code I would love for you to get on that
newsletter at davidpackman.com you'll be
notified first thing Monday morning and
then we will welcome you with open arms
into the ranks of membership
if you are still looking for the perfect
Father's Day gift check this out guys
know that it can be tough to find good
boxers and t-shirts but the search can
end now because our sponsor Leisure of
NYC sells the most comfortable t-shirts
and boxers that your dad is ever going
to wear all boxer briefs by Leisure of
NYC are made with amazingly soft
moisture wicking viscose from bamboo
feels lightweight like air but it
doesn't Bunch up it's also better for
the planet Leisure of NYC also makes
these incredible supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts for men less than one percent
of men's Basics today are made with
supima cotton it's really the best out
there it just feels almost like Silk you
can let your dad walk around in a
scratchy t-shirt all day but come on you
can also treat him with the cloud soft
feel of supima button so that it'll
actually love the shirt these are always
my go-to shirts and boxers no other
company even comes close to the Comfort
they provide and all of their products
are fair trade and made sustainably go
to davidpackman.com
NYC and you'll get 15 off with the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below
an anti-transgender mom was interviewed
on CNN it uh is extraordinarily
disturbing and sad and I'm gonna play it
for you and we're going to talk through
some of the things that were said this
is Darcy shoning the chapter chair for
moms for Liberty in El Paso County
Colorado
Darcy is very very worried she's worried
that there are multiple forces at play
that want to convince our children to
become gay or trans which I feel like a
even saying because anybody who
understands being gay or trans realizes
that this concept makes absolutely no
sense nor does the nor do any of the
parties mentioned have any interest in
convincing people to be gay or trans
however what I what I do want to point
to in this interview is the interviewer
El Reeve asks why would teachers unions
or abide why would they want to convince
people to be gay or trans Darcy has an
answer
it's an idiotic answer it's an easily
debunkable answer it's an answer that
makes no sense whatsoever unless you
understand nothing about anything but
she has an answer so we're going to be
able to analyze it for what it is all
right let's take a listen to this behind
your parents back I got your back I mean
there's a clear move to bring more of
that into our school than it's just not
the school's place so
would I feel like you're strongly
implying and I would like to get your
take on because I don't want to
attribute something that you don't think
but to me it sounds like you're saying
there's some kind of high level
coordinated effort to make more children
trans and get away yeah
well who's directing that teachers
unions and
um our president and a lot of funding
sources and teaching which she doesn't
mention so that's teachers unions
our president which at least she
acknowledges Biden as the president
teachers unions Biden and a lot of
funding sources want to make kids gay
and transunions are also have heavily
backing the curriculum that we're
bringing into school why would they want
more kids to be gay in Trails because it
breaks down the family unit which breaks
down traditional conservative values it
breaks down a lot of things in this
country it changes the way that people
think it changes the way that people
handle politics of course there's no
evidence of a coordinated plot to make
kids trans
when I hear those
thoughts about like some sort of
concerted effort to make people get does
it sound like a conspiracy theory to you
um it's not a conspiracy theory that
this state whether you're talking about
Colorado or the federal government is
taking a house stronger and stronger
hand in public education in raising our
kids there's a big jump from that
to what she's claiming so do I think
that
for some reason people want everyone to
be gay that's a mischaracterialization
of what I think I think that people will
use you know the people that want to
erode away at parental rights the left
the teachers unions they'll use lgbtq or
whatever may be the case at the time
those are yeah so she's like it's not
that they want to make everyone gay or
trans they just want to make a lot more
people gay and trans and the critical
line from this is she says that because
it's a good question right why would
anyone want to do this what's the
political goal in making more people gay
and trans kids if you could do such a
thing and she says it will break down
the family unit and it will break down
conservative values well what's
interesting about I mean think that
through
right
if you have a child
and the child is gay
it only breaks down the family unit if
the parents reject the kid and kick them
out of the house which sometimes happens
right when you actually think about what
she's saying you realize that's only the
case if we treat LGBT folks terribly
including LGBT kids so let's go through
a couple of these these ideas here first
is the notion that teachers unions have
adopted this secret mission to undermine
the family unit and conservative values
by trying to convince children to take
on these identities there's no evidence
of that but the suggestion would make
you believe or suggest to you that
Educators who go through all of the
schooling that they go through
bachelor's degree typically master's
degree they learn how to teach how to
impart knowledge how to uh educate young
minds all of these things
their actual plan all along was to be
social Engineers to get themselves into
classrooms in order to convince children
to be gay specifically to tear families
apart by destroying the fan family unit
through such social engineering that's
an insane thing to accuse teachers of
doing because you have to when they
vaguely say the teachers union
you you think of this monolith this
almost like a corporation of sorts but
then you think through and you go oh
okay the third grade teacher who is now
in debt because of the Masters in
Education that they have and they're
underpaid and blah blah blah they did
all of it not because they genuinely
want to teach kids but because they have
this clandestine mission to turn kids
gay and trans and that's how they want
to shape the country through social
engineering it's an outrageous thing to
suggest then there's will Biden wants
the same thing
I I mean you know if if anything can be
said about Joe Biden it's that his focus
on LGBT issues has not been overwhelming
I mean yes he's done a couple events at
the White House and welcomed people or
whatever he's treating people with with
respect but the idea that that's Biden's
goal but also the idea that that this
alleged obsessive focus on turning
people kids gay and trans by Biden would
gain him political Capital when it's
known to be such a controversial issue
thanks to right Wingers that doesn't
make any sense in any way and then
lastly she throws in this and there are
also funding sources that want more gay
and trans people
she doesn't name those sources I think
unless she does it's very hard to take
it seriously but you you have to
understand what's at this core
a very benign and milk toast
sort of Declaration that we should treat
people with respect we should have basic
inclusivity in schools when it comes to
LGBT people like that's what's really
going on like let's treat people with
respect in some places we have to figure
out what to do about bathrooms because
it's like a tactical issue a practical
issue yes and some there are some sports
related questions to figure out but
basically what we're saying is let's let
everybody feel comfortable
and let's prevent people from feeling
under threat based on their identity
because that's what gives those folks
and as a result society as a whole the
greater chance to flourish and provide
everybody equal rights and opportunities
under the law that's that's all that's
going on
and they see that as an attack
they see it as an attack on quote
conservative values they see it as an
attack on the quote family unit as Darcy
shoning says in this interview
that's what this is really about
leveling the playing field so that it's
not openly okay to discriminate against
minority groups they see as an attack
and that tells you a lot about what
these folks are thinking I'm going to
play a clip for you a Fox News
propagandist Laura Ingraham
casually mentioning before a commercial
break oh this story about uh vets being
thrown out of hotels to put in illegals
turns out the story was completely false
don't know why anybody would make it up
we'll talk to you later see you on
tomorrow's show very casually saying
that entire story my whole network
covered for days
turns out it was made up
it happened so quickly you might not
even notice it listen to this all right
before we go a little update on a story
we brought you this week about homeless
vets being displaced from hotels so that
illegals could move in turns out the
group behind the claim made it up
we have no clue as to why anyone would
do such a thing but we'll bring you any
updates should they come
that is that this is crazy stuff guys
this is really really crazy we ran
stories non-stop for a week based on no
sourcing on a total lie and we got
caught
we don't know why anyone would make this
up because they got you to cover it
Laura this is the entire point the the
false naivete
why would anyone make up a story that
makes Biden look bad and undocumented
immigrants look bad and makes veterans
appear to be the victims of undocumented
immigrants why would anyone make that up
well it's because this is what your
network traffic's in Laura uh some other
guy also issued this retraction was like
Mar this one was 30 seconds instead of
20 seconds quick update on a story from
earlier this week about homeless
veterans being displaced from a hotel in
Newburgh New York to make room for
migrants we're now looking into new
reports that a veteran's Advocate misled
lawmakers about or and media Outlets
about a story that some homeless men may
have been hired to pose as veterans that
the equivocation we're looking into some
claims that maybe someone else lied and
it's possible like the entire thing was
a complete hoax meant to fire people up
we've reached out to the Organization
for a statement but so far have not
heard back we'll send it back to you
yeah there's enough chaos with that
potentially false stories running around
out there yeah we it's too chaotic out
there for false stories to be running
around unchecked which we do all the
time which we do all the time there's a
Daily Beast article that sums this up
Fox News stoked outrage over migrants
displacing homeless vets it was a hoax
Fox News and the rest of right-wing
media went wild for a week over a now
debunked story about New York hotels
booting homeless vets to accommodate
Asylum Seekers this is what they do and
the false innocence we can't imagine why
why would anyone make this up well why
did people make things up about Hillary
and Obama and Biden and Hunter Biden and
whistleblowers that don't exist this is
what they do to try to convince people
to come to their political side and this
is the equivalent of a week of page on
newspaper headlines and then a Sunday
retraction on page B12
uh it's it's the same thing a week of
headlines headlines headlines the five
with a big Blockbuster discussion who is
really the worst person involved in this
situation where vets are being kicked
out to put undocumented immigrants in
they don't call them undocumented
immigrants by the way and then oh real
quick before we go it's 9 59 and 40
seconds now uh before we go that uh
story seems someone made it up we don't
know why but uh we'll look into it
anyway and of course only a fraction of
the audience sees the retraction and the
cycle continues and continues Laura
Ingram and the entire network should be
ashamed of themselves particularly in
the midst of hundreds of millions of
dollars in lawsuits actually billions in
lawsuits with nearly a billion in
settlements so far over untrue things
that they have said
disgusting and the Casual nature with
with which they do the retraction is
just like the cherry on top or the
bottom of the barrel or call it what you
will
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
we are going to talk a little bit more
about the 2024 Republican primary we
will talk about three potential or
actual candidates a little bit later I
will talk about an actual candidate
Donald Trump we will then also talk
about a potential candidate Ron DeSantis
and first I'm going to tell you about
the newest candidate and I'm talking
about Tim Scott Tim Scott the only black
Republican senator currently in the
Senate from South Carolina has announced
that he is running in the Republican
primary in 2024 the Associated Press
reports Senator Tim Scott makes it
official he's a republican candidate for
president now we're going to talk about
some of the details here but let me
bottom line this for you the 40 000 foot
view on Tim Scott's candidacy is number
one Dead on Arrival number two how on
Earth is the party that most recently
selected as their candidate an old white
guy who regularly stoked fears about
brown and black people how is that very
same electorate going to say hey you
know what
let's elect a black guy instead of trump
when Trump is actually running again you
don't really need to know anything else
about Tim Scott's candidacy other than
that the the same voters aren't going to
go from the white guy stoking fears
about brown and black people to a black
guy they're just not going to do it now
let's go through some of the details
here Associated Press reports Senator
Tim Scott of South Carolina makes it
official he's running Scott the Senate's
only black Republican filed paperwork
declaring his intention to seek the
nomination I love this line
his can't the Associated Press sometimes
they're the the neutrality with which
they report certain things is actually
funny his candidacy will test whether a
more optimistic version of a vision of
America's future can resonate with
Republican voters who have elevated
partisan Brawlers in recent years I can
give you the answer no they are not
going to go with a more optimistic
Vision the deeply religious 57 year old
former insurance broker has made his
grandfather's work in the cotton fields
of the deep south of Bedrock of his
political identity yet he rejects the
notion that racism remains a powerful
force in society he is cast as candidacy
and rise from generational poverty as
the realization of a dream only possible
in America he has ads scheduled to begin
in Iowa and New Hampshire starting uh
this week it's all it's all happening
okay we're really getting into the thick
of the 2024 primary now let me tell you
a couple of different things if we put
aside for a second the undeniable
reality that this campaign is indeed
Dead on Arrival Tim Scott has no chance
he's polling you know one percent two
percent whatever
there is something very dangerous about
Tim Scott Tim Scott openly says openly
says that religion
but not any religion his Christian
religion should guide and direct civil
government in the United States that is
an extraordinarily dangerous Vision now
of course when we look at Trump Trump's
foreign policy ideas are dangerous Trump
being enamored with right-wing dictators
and authoritarians is dangerous Trump's
cluelessness on everything from
International Trade to economics to
social issues it's all very dangerous
but Trump stops short of openly saying
that what was it uh government should
kneel at the altar of religion or I
forget exactly what phrase Tim Scott
used that is also genuinely dangerous in
how Brazen a 180 it is from what the
founders of the United States actually
wanted so is it a good thing that Trump
is crushing Tim Scott and Tim Scott has
no chance well it is what it is I can't
help the fact that Maga still controls
the Republican party we don't want a guy
close to the presidency
who overtly believes that not just any
religion but his religion should control
civil government and that's what Tim
Scott believes now more generally on
politics you know Tim Scott is an
extreme right-winger we shouldn't he's
less cartoonish than Trump in some ways
but we should all understand the degree
to which these are true extremists he
opposes abortion he says crazy things
about the Border he was a no on
conviction for Trump in both impeachment
trials he delivered a completely
outrageous response to Joe Biden's
address to Congress where he said there
simply is no racism here anymore and it
doesn't matter and
according to Real Clear Politics Trump
is polling about 56 percent DeSantis
around 20 as I told you and Tim Scott on
average has two percent Tim Scott is
behind Mike Pence who's not even running
Tim Scott is behind Nikki Haley and
Vivek ramaswamy who are running but also
have no chance Larry Elder and some
polls is doing better than Tim Scott
even though Larry Elder as far as I know
isn't running but who even knows because
no one's paying attention to Larry Elder
so Tim Scott has absolutely no chance
the question then becomes what's the
reason to do this what is he thinking
what does he think he can do does he
literally think he can win over Trump
supporters and convince them to abandon
Trump and vote for Tim Scott no I think
there's no chance in hell of that does
he think that the same party who voted
the guy
into power who encouraged hostility
against black and brown people is now
going to vote for a black guy in the
primary it's very hard to believe Tim
Scott believes that I mean Tim Scott is
a dangerous extremist but he's not quite
literally a stupid guy in the
traditional sense so what is his
motivation my instinct is that when
these guys run candidacies determined to
lose they make the call that if they can
make it onto a debate stage or two or
raise money with which they can run ads
in a bunch of different states they're
raising their name recognition and maybe
securing their their spot in the Senate
I I don't know I mean it's it's all very
confusing when I see these sorts of
candidacies but Tim Scott running
will not be the Republican nominee
almost laughable to think that he has a
shop and Vivek ramaswamy has no shot
Nikki Haley has no shot it's can
DeSantis do something
to get to 50 percent
and I struggle to think of what that
could be or does Trump just easily
assail to the nomination let's go now
from Tim Scott to Ron DeSantis Ron
DeSantis still has not successfully
received a personality transplant that
is going to help him in any way I'm
going to play some cringe video for you
it's difficult to imagine a less
charismatic Guy The New York Times wrote
up his uh DeSantis recent trip to New
Hampshire
DeSantis amps up his retail campaign in
New Hampshire the Florida governor met
with State lawmakers and made the
Standard Diner visit to press flesh with
voters showcasing his more moderate side
he was not showcasing his most moderate
side he bragged about banning pronouns
but more importantly
look at the lack of charisma
it's hard to think of a more awkward and
less charismatic guy here's the sand as
I'll describe this for people not
watching DeSantis enters a diner seems
visibly confused as to how to relate to
people and is kind of told where to
stand and it's
I almost started feeling bad for the guy
because it's almost like when an
introvert is forced into social
situations
ah take a look at this how are you doing
wow look at this Hi how are you guys
good to see you so what do you got go
right over here okay good deal good deal
good deal good deal go hey guys how you
doing oh stand here oh uh yes absolutely
biscuits yes biscuits wow crowded huh
there are people in this establishment
which suggests that business is
transacting how are you doing
that was really good I'll tell you that
you know when these lgbtq smells we
we're doing away with that in Florida
we're just not gonna do it because it
woke goes to die in Florida and if
anybody tries to slide turkey bacon in
it it is only real bacon none of that
stuff okay I'll tell you that
right now so we'll do it okay
how are you I'm wonderful great to be up
here I love that what's your name Tim
okay
and it's such a little thing but it's
again he just
every detail of what's your name oh my
my name's uh uh Jonathan okay
wow what what a guy
stay tuned
are you gonna run stay tuned all right
all right then he also during the same
stop I think or maybe this was a
different Diner looks like he's in a I
don't know where he is same same sort of
thing
um he bragged about how they've banned
pronouns in Florida we just did a bill
in Florida we're not allowing the
pronouns like you can't force these kids
to be choosing they want like a second
grader
listen and if you elect me president I'm
gonna go after adverbs and prepositional
phrases we're gonna just end those like
you wouldn't even believe because these
woke people they want to put and by the
way capitalization on proper nouns we're
gonna get rid of that so fast that
they're gonna get the hell out of
Florida this guy is not ready
he is not ready and it's
constitutionally he just
appealing to moderate voters is what was
reported by the New York Times he
bragged about banning pronouns there is
nothing moderate about that and by the
way if you can say a lot of bad things
about New Hampshire not the state but
what I'm saying there's a lot of
right-wing extremism in New Hampshire
focusing on pronouns I don't even know
is that it's going to do it with New
Hampshire Republicans to be totally
honest so the DeSantis campaign that
still hasn't started looking very very
rough Donald Trump has received
disastrous news from his own former
lawyer Ty Cobb his name is really Ty
Cobb Ty Cobb believes
Trump will end up convicted and in
prison
for one of Trump's own former lawyers to
say this is really something Donald
Trump's former attorney has boldly
predicted that the former president is
going to jail
as the criminal investigation into the
Trove of classified documents found at
Mar-A-Lago continues to heat up Ty Cobb
who worked as a White House attorney for
the Trump Administration from July 2017
to May 2018 said to CNN the evidence
against Trump will lead to a conviction
and prison time reminder this is
separate from Georgia where an
indictment may be coming this is
separate from the pre-existing arrest
and indictment of trump this is its own
this is for the the documents in Florida
quote I wouldn't necessarily expand the
case to try to prove the Espionage Act
piece of it because there's so much
evidence of guilty knowledge on the
Espionage piece that all they really
have to do is show that Trump moved
these documents at various times when
doj was either demanding them or
actually present that he filed falsely
with the justice department had his
lawyers file falsely with the justice
department and affidavit to the effect
that none existed meaning no documents
which was shattered by the documents
they discovered after the search and the
many other misrepresentations yes I do
think he will go to jail on it
uh Business Insider reports a former
White House lawyer believes Trump will
go to jail Ty Cobb said there was quote
so much evidence of guilty knowledge as
investigations continue the doj is
probing whether Trump obstructed Justice
in bringing classified documents to
Mar-A-Lago
if other people did what Trump did they
would certainly be prosecuted now you
know sometimes you'll see legal analysts
or non-usually it's more like non-legal
analysts say anybody who did this would
be convicted and sentenced to prison
conviction is a much different thing
right the criminal standard of guilt
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
it's very hard to predict conviction but
what we can say with certainty is that
if other people did what Trump did with
regard to the documents they would
certainly be prosecuted and then we
would look at whether they get convicted
and the most important aspect of all of
this is that no one should be above the
law should being the critical word
the last part of this
speculating on the outcome of ongoing
investigations in a sense can be
misleading and it is true that when you
hear a lawyer like Ty Cobb say you go
wow this this is not just a random
lawyer this is not a random left-wing
lawyer this is a lawyer who worked for
Trump and that does carry strength and
so I think we should listen to what Ty
Cobb says at the same time
investigations can be fickle these
things have to run their course we want
impartiality when it comes to the
justice system and so when Ty Cobb makes
these predictions they're worth noting
given his knowledge and associations
with a former president Donald Trump but
also we should approach all of it with
caution let the investigations play out
and be guided by evidence and for the
time being I have every reason to
believe that that is exactly
what the justice department has been
doing
I can't imagine if you are Trump you're
thrilled when your own former lawyer
says I think you're going to prison but
let's wait and see because it's
certainly one of many possible outcomes
here
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show radical
and repugnant Republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green suffered another
public humiliation she seems to have a
very high tolerance for these as she is
constantly embarrassing and humiliating
herself in public fortunately her
constituents don't seem to care let me
tell you what happened there was a
hearing about extremism white supremacy
criminality so on and so forth and one
of the witnesses during this hearing was
a woman named Amy spitalnik and she's a
senior advisor on extremism at the human
rights organization human rights first
not only did Marjorie Taylor green
mispronounce her her name which we will
get to in a moment
but she seemed to once again lose a
sense of how time moves forward and 2023
happened after 2024 and so on and so
forth and when the witness tried to
explain that every single politically
motivated murder in 2022 was committed
by a right-wing extremist Marjorie
Taylor green brings up something that
happened in 2023 and as if green is a
five-year-old it's explained to her that
it's a different year congresswoman when
it comes to politically motivated
violence in 2022 every single murder was
committed by a right-wing extremist
every single murder in America was
committed by a right-wing every single
politically motivated murder was
committed by a right-wing extremist are
you sure about that are you are you
aware that the Tennessee shooter just
recently identified as a man and she was
a biological woman was she a right-wing
extremist as well young lady time is
expired I'll allow the witness to answer
the question so that was a shooting that
happened in 2023
there is no evidence as to what ideology
motivated that shooting when it
there's a lot here this is this is
actually
it's it's another humiliation for
Marjory Taylor green but there is a lot
here first of all
imagine that
it were true
that all but one politically motivated
shootings were committed by
right-wingers and imagine that the
shooting that Marjorie Taylor green is
referring to had happened in 2022.
it's actually almost worse because the
fact that Marjorie Taylor green would be
able to say well there there was this
one shooting that wasn't a right winger
it would only reinforce that the
politically motivated shootings in the
United States are almost exclusively
committed by right-wingers now it
happens that Marjorie Taylor green
brought up a shooting that didn't happen
in 2022 it happened in 2023 so it just
doesn't even make any sense but imagine
that conversation every single one of
these was committed by uh by
right-wingers well other than this one
oh okay all but one so it's still 99
it's still not good
now it's also true that even in the
incident this year
with the Trans shooter
we know the identity of the individual
as being trans but as far as I've seen
we actually don't know the motivations
and just because you're trans doesn't
mean that the motivations were left-wing
motivations if they were I will
absolutely tell you it wouldn't change
the reality that overwhelmingly
politically motivated shootings in the
United States are committed by
right-wingers so just an embarrassment
up and down the in the entire thing
um here's the moment earlier during this
where Marjorie Taylor green
mispronounces the witness's name and
then tries this hardcore questioning
which just makes her look like a
horrible person that she is a Miss
spittle neck you were talking about
white suprematomic oh I apologize but
tall Nick Miss batalnick while you were
talking about white supremacist and
abortion I totally agree with you
there's a lot of white supremacist
supremacists in the abortion movement
and abortionists because they have
murdered over 20 million black babies in
America since Roe versus Wade in 1973
that's on average 900 black babies are
aborted they're ripped apart inside
their mother's womb this is gag worthy
stuff from Marjorie Taylor Greene James
so I you know I would agree with you
that that could be labeled white
supremacy or we could just label it
murder and it should never be happening
so if you want to talk about white
supremacy and the abortion movement you
should really analyze that in your human
rights groups that you run as you
collect donations from people with your
non-profit because I think that is
something extremely important to talk
about yeah because Marjorie Taylor green
doesn't grift for donations right is the
right for those black babies to have
lives as American citizens the right for
them to be born the right for them to be
given a chance to live is free Americans
instead of murder you think this is
funny Miss patalneck is this funny to
you as babies being murdered in the womb
funny to you because you're smirking and
laughing this is a very tough Marjorie
Taylor green me right now what's not
funny are the black people and Hispanic
people and Jewish people and Muslim
people who have been murdered in
synagogue in church in supermarkets in
mosque by white supremacists are you
aware that that all colored people are
murdered uh that is that is a fact that
every single color person has been
murdered that that's not unusual pick a
color they've been murdered says
Marjorie Taylor green it's not just that
people have come the question is what
are the motivations for those murders
which seems to be completely above
Marjorie Taylor Green's head or murdered
white people are murdered too murder is
not just for minorities that may be a
shock to you so a disgusting person
Marjorie Taylor green and as usual she's
not good at this she will try to make
these Witnesses look bad and she fails
that being said the people who like
Marjorie Taylor green see that and think
wow she did a really good job she really
showed that witness she really proved
her wrong
um a common sense approach leads you to
a different conclusion but a lot of this
is what can I go back to my constituents
and justify what can I go on Hannity and
claim that I did but to any thinking
person really a humiliation that
Marjorie Taylor green is even a member
of the United States House of
Representatives that's really you know
the number one thing I hear from our
foreign viewers about Marjorie Taylor
green it's not about her specific views
as deplorable as they are
it's the disbelief that she could even
get elected in this country how how does
your country elect this person and then
you go down to whatever fourth fourth or
14th District of Georgia wherever she
represents and you talk to people and
you go oh this is how
this is how
they are thinking about investigating
Hillary Clinton do not adjust your
television do not uh uh go back 15
seconds on your podcast player it is May
of 2023 and they are looking at an
investigation into Bill and Hillary
Clinton Jim Jordan appeared standing and
with no suit jacket as he always does on
Maria bartiromo's show yesterday morning
on Fox News Maria Bartiromo is a Fox
News propagandist and Trump brown noser
who screams most of the show I don't
know why you could just turn up her
microphone if you thought she needed
more volume and she gets Jim Jordan to
seemingly tease
that they're going to look into an
investigation into Hillary and maybe
Bill Clinton as well as you can see
House Republicans has taken control in
January they really have their fingers
on the pulse of the issues of importance
to the American people real quick do you
want to see another investigation of
Hillary and Bill Clinton because the
Durham report John Durham wrote that
while they were pursuing Trump they made
no effort to investigate the claim that
Hillary Clinton was taking money from
Foreigners for her Clinton Global
initiative and the Clinton Foundation
they not only did investigate her like
they did President Trump they gave her
oh they're both screaming today campaign
a defensive briefing right they should
have done the same for president Trump
because they literally had no evidence
so we're going to talk with our lawyers
we're going to talk with speaker
McCarthy on where we proceed from from
here in fact are there people that were
that were highlighted in the Durham
investigation and the Durham report that
we need to talk to on the Judiciary
Committee we're going to give that a
good hard look but nothing is off the
table because it is even Hillary's on
the table the American people understand
how their government their agencies have
been turned on them the taxpayer and we
get all the facts out there Mr chairman
real quick
uh I hope they finally get to the bottom
of the Lewinsky scandal I really do
because I've been waiting around
nobody's really given it a good hard
look and I think it's time that we
figure out what the hell happened back
in the 90s with Bill Clinton maybe go
back even further I want them to look at
some of the things that Hillary did when
Bill was governor of Arkansas because I
think that's really where the bodies are
buried as they love to say these people
they're nuts but I wouldn't put it past
them to actually try to investigate
Hillary we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P here's a call
about tipping a subject about which I
feel very strongly
do you like to give tips at restaurants
no but I do it
I think that people should stop tipping
at restaurants
you might say well that's bad for the
you know Bakers well
if you keep tipping at a restaurant
the restaurant owner
will continue to not pay a living wage
to the waitress or bartender
if everyone stops tipping
then obviously the waitress and
bartender will leave and not work at the
restaurant
and now the restaurant is stuck with
food that they can serve to their
customers
and when that happens
they will either
close shop
or re-evaluate their
payroll
and they will also reevaluate their
prices so listen I wanna I've been up
front I hate tipping culture and how it
has developed I don't like the
inconsistency of it I don't like the
increased nature of more and more places
where you're you're allowed to tip a lot
of this is driven by companies like
square and stripe who put those payment
tablets they collect a portion of every
dollar so it's to the advantage of the
companies that do the payment tablets to
offer tipping for everything and then a
we'll just collect more money
um I tip well everywhere I go I tip
housekeeping when I stay in a hotel and
I you know uh the valet people i t i I
tip everywhere but I am very very much
against the entire thing the problem
with saying if we just stop tipping the
restaurants will have to adjust first of
all the Tipping has gone Way Beyond
restaurant at this point and the first
thing that's going going to happen is if
restaurants immediately play that out
and by the way some states some state
law
allow the my understanding is that if
the tips don't get that tipped wage up
to the minimum wage the restaurant owner
already has to make up that difference
that's my belief but we should we should
fact check that in in the immediate if
restaurants all of a sudden because
everybody stop tipping needed to pay
employees dramatically more they would
immediately increase prices
significantly at the restaurant now this
is effectively what has happened the
tips subsidize and this is what has
happened at restaurants that now say we
include a service charge please don't
tip and the prices already reflect that
the 12 sandwich might just cost you 15
but they will say please don't tip we
have a service charger many restaurants
in New York City have already done this
you look at the menu and it says we are
we pay our employees well the price is
already reflect that or we have added a
four percent surcharge for the back of
the house and and tip is already
inclusive on the prices or whatever the
case may be honestly I'm I'm more or
less for that sort of thing and I know
that at least in the immediate we're
just going to pay more in order to not
tip but there are a bunch of different
issues with the The Tipping model and it
includes that when people come from
different countries you don't always
know what's expected I was recently in
the UK
the UK has now taken to they
automatically include 12 and a half
percent so you don't have to think about
it you can ask for it to be removed but
the bill comes out and it automatically
says 12 and a half percent tip and what
I like about that is I don't have to
think about it it just is what it is but
my preference would be eliminate tipping
put real pricing that reflects the total
cost of paying employees well on the
menu and then I can look at the menu and
determine whether I think that this is a
restaurant that I want to visit but I
think that if we all just stop tipping
cold turkey it'll be terrible for
workers I don't believe it'll have the
effect that our caller believes it will
have remember Monday Memorial Day this
coming Monday our one day membership
special if you're thinking about signing
up I would encourage you to do so at a
humiliatingly huge discount that we will
be offering on Monday you can be
notified via email by getting on our
newsletter at davidpackman.com bonus
show today will be great we'll talk
about the 1.3 billion dollar fine that
meta has been hit with we will talk
about the move to expel Adam Schiff from
Congress and we will talk about the
latest with the city bike lawsuit that
is going on it's crazy all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad I can't possibly
say it any better than that so we will
end the show and see you on the bonus
show or back here tomorrow
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpackman.com NYC